[Musique]
heures de pointe sur l'un des accès au
centre-ville de tours la voiture devient
chaque jour plus envahissante
avec des conséquences dramatiques pour
l'environnement et la santé pour
reprendre le contrôle les pouvoirs
publics ont adopté quelques décisions
fortes comme la loi de transition
énergétique de 2015 qui promet de nous
faire passer à marche forcée dans un
monde plus propre ou encore le plan
climat de nicolas hulot qui promet
d'éliminer tous les véhicules thermiques
d'ici 2040 le gasoil c'est dépassé place
à la fée électricité
elle s'appelle le ix onic zoé lyon et se
multiplient silencieuse dans nos rues
alors dans cet avenir qu'on nous promet
vertueux la voiture électrique est elle
la solution miracle où en est on
aujourd'hui de son développement et
comment s'y retrouver dans les offres
des constructeurs
parole d'expert
aujourd'hui on trouve sur le marché ce
qu'on appelle l'hybride c'est la
combinaison d'un moteur électrique et
d'un moteur thermique qui peut être
essence ou diesel
il ya aussi l'hybride rechargeable la
différence c'est que on peut faire un
trajet en mode purement électrique sur
quelques dizaines de kilomètres en
général une cinquantaine et puis est ce
qu'on appelle le véhicule 100%
électrique
là il n'y a plus de moteur il ya
simplement un moteur électrique et une
batterie de plus grande capacité
avec une autonomie en général autour de
300 km pour les modèles les plus
performants
la bonne question à se poser toujours
c'est quel usage je fais de mon véhicule
si par exemple pour la deuxième voiture
du foyer c'est pour faire un trajet de
20 kilomètres par jour
un véhicule électrique fera la sphère
largement d'ailleurs on leur chargera
dans le meilleur des cas que en fin de
semaine simplement si maintenant on a
une combinaison entre trajets domicile
travail la semaine mais que c'est la
voiture principale est que le week-end
on en a besoin pour des grands trajets
dans ce cas une voiture hybride ou
hybrides rechargeables peut
effectivement faire la faire tout
électrique
c'est le choix de jean paul pour la
deuxième voiture de sa famille
enseignant chercheur il habite notre
dame d'oé se rend tous les jours à tour
pour son travail sa conversion véhicules
électriques reste une affaire de plaisir
c'est le côté écologique bien sûr mais
c'est également fait que c'est
extrêmement agréable à conduire le
silence d'abord évidemment et puis la
souplesse pas vraiment on travaille
toujours un peu loin de domicile et il y
avait
et toujours une voiture un peu grande un
peu qui nous permettait de partir et
puis une voiture plus petite qui nous
permettait de faire des petits trajets
donc cette voiture a remplacé la
deuxième petite voiture avec cinq ans
d'expérience et soixante dix neuf mille
kilomètres au compteur de sa petite
voiture électrique
jean-paul en a acquis tous les
automatismes de retour chez lui un seul
geste suffit à assurer ses trajets
domicile travail quotidien là on fait le
point qui sera pendant la nuit
je fais dès que je fais en dessous de la
moitié de la charge ce qui m'arrive tous
les deux trois jours
c'est un geste que on a vraiment
l'habitude on se gare juste devant et
puis et puis on charge
on ne vit pas du tout comme une
contrainte
un petit déjeuner rapide pour démarrer
cette nouvelle journée mais avant de
monter en voiture il faut au préalable
répondre à la question rituelle du matin
lequel des deux prendra l'électrique et
le qu'elle optera pour le vieux diesel
est celui qui fait le plus de kilomètres
qui prend la voiture on décide un petit
peu chaque jour en fonction de notre
emploi du temps
le manque d'autonomie a longtemps freiné
le développement du véhicule électrique
pas de bornes de recharge pas
d'électricité pas d'électricité pas de
voiture électrique une équation simple
et dans ce domaine l'indre et loire fait
figure de très bon élève avec ses 400
bornes réparties sur tout son territoire
ce maillage remarquable c'est un
organisme public qu'on le doit le
syndicat intercommunal d'électricité la
volonté du syndicat ça a été de
développer les bornes sur l'ensemble de
son territoire et pas seulement sur les
grands centres urbains
on a une répartition à peu près d'un
d'une borne tous les 20 30 km est
évidemment mon sur certaines communes de
l'agglomération tour on a plusieurs
bornes de recharge puisque évidemment on
a demandé un peu plus forte aujourd'hui
leur déploiement est à peu près terminée
et pour les automobilistes en transit
six points de recharge rapide ont
également été installés à proximité des
sorties des autoroutes
l'autre pari du ciel c'est de rendre
l'ensemble de ces bornes compatibles
avec tout un réseau d'opérateurs
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec mon outil carte ici
j'accède à plusieurs milliers de points
de charge dans le monde avec un seul
outil
j'arrive devant le point j'aime
référence bip
il vient de bip et je choisis mon type
de charge ici c'est la mennais caisse
pour le pour le véhicule jeu-là
déverrouille jeu laplug sur mon véhicule
voilà je reviens je déverrouille je m'en
vais dans n'importe quel endroit du
territoire je réserve à distance j'ai
l'information des tarifs
je suis super déçue marquardt jette un
seul outil de paiement grâce à ce
maillage de points de charge le nombre
de voitures électriques est dans le
département de l'indre et loire trois
fois et demi supérieur à la moyenne
nationale
[Musique]
donc là on a démarré à l'heure avec tel
ou tel modèle économique est enclenché
un mode qui va limiter l'accélération
avoir un peu brutale accélération une
bonne dose de stress pour adeline après
quelques échecs dans son apprentissage
sur voitures traditionnelles la voici
aujourd'hui au volant d'une voiture
électrique
et c'est son deuxième court donc à
droite donc wacom régime de priorité
on retrouve à jean à l'issue de celles
son impression super voiture sont pas de
bruit super car j'adore ça il y a trois
ans cette auto école a été l'une des
toutes premières à acquérir une voiture
électrique à double commande
[Musique]
voilà pour qu'il fasse dans la conduite
totalement dissociable de l'éco conduite
ça veut dire que quand on va aborder ces
véhicules là on va vraiment s'intéresser
bas des modes de conduite économique
dans la conduite ça change pas grand
chose voire même rien on a les mêmes les
mêmes caractéristiques qu'une voiture
automatique normal que la simple
différence c'est qu'effectivement le
silence peu un petit peu déroutés au
début dans la mesure où à la perfection
la vitesse est un petit peu faussé par
rapport au silence de fonctionnement
dans les grosses entreprises publiques
comme privées la transition vers la
motorisation électrique devient peu à
peu une réalité
à la poste on a misé sur la
diversification vos côtés des
fourgonnettes et des vélos à assistance
électrique
on trouve d'autres engins plus
surprenant
[Musique]
revue de détail nous avons un trois
roues électriques qui s'appelle le
tabbee en raison de sa stabilité pour
les peaux les facteurs c'est un modèle
spécialement conçu pour la poste par
ligier qui permet vraiment de s'adapter
aux tournées notamment de centre-ville
avec une capacité aussi d'emport
importante
et puis vous avez à côté de celui ci le
quad électrique qui lui aussi est adapté
aux zones urbaines et périurbaines
nous sommes sur la plateforme de
joué-lès-tours soixante mille courriers
sont triés ici chaque jour avant d'être
distribué dans les boîtes aux lettres
les facteurs préparent leur tournée le
ballet des véhicules va pouvoir
commencer
je fais une tournée à montjoie yeux en
ville et donc je monte dans le véhicule
et on est parti qu'est ce que c'est
comme type de véhicule un quad et au
fait qu'il ya conduit pas du tout
[Musique]
le petit véhicule est commode il se
faufile partout
souple et silencieux c'est assez
agréable surtout quand on est en ville
et en plus on n'a pas besoin de passer
les vitesses
donc c'est limité à 50 ans qu'on n'a pas
besoin de surveiller à condé enroulé cas
pas de souci
depuis 2013 la poste a réduit de 15 %
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
une démarche vertueuse qui devrait se
poursuivre dans les prochaines années
[Applaudissements]
mais la voiture électrique ne fait pas
que des heureux et les expériences
tourne parfois au fiasco en septembre
2014 le service avait été inauguré en
grande pompe la société d'autopartage
cities installait dans le quartier des
deux lions une station de véhicules 100%
électriques
quatre ans plus tard la station n'existe
plus l'expérience n'a pas été reconduite
et les douze voitures de citis
fonctionne tout à l'essence explications
la vertu de l'autopartage c'est la
mutualisation des voitures et le fait de
remplacer des voitures personnelles par
une voiture mutualiser et la dea et la
motorisation est secondaire aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut pas faire c'est aller vers
des véhicules électriques qui en termes
de coût de revient reviennent quand même
plus cher nécessite une borne électrique
beaucoup de temps pour recharger et en
même temps qu'ils font un petit nombre
de kilomètres en ville ce qui pose des
problèmes en termes économiques
peut-être un jour l'autopartage
s'intéressera tel de nouveau à
l'électricité mais plus encore que pour
les particuliers autonomie temps de
charger coût à l'achat des véhicules en
constituent les trois conditions et les
pouvoirs publics se sont ils eux aussi
véritablement engagés dans cette
démarche la loi de transition
énergétique leur encre et l'obligation
mais dans les transports en commun ce
petit bus électriques qui sillonnent
rues et ruelles du vieux tours fait
encore figure d'exception
pour cet élu écologiste la métropole ne
va pas assez vite
encore là il ya peu de temps j'ai
demandé à ce que la métropole annonce la
sortie du diesel sur ses véhicules
aussi bien les bus que les bennes à
ordures qui elles aussi sont des
véhicules diesel et donc on peut faire
des choses on peut montrer l'exemple en
tous les cas et la métropole à ce droit
à ce devoir d'exemplarité et on n'en est
pas là nous avons hâte rameau une
première ligne vingt-et-une ram qui sont
électriques 100 % électrique donc la
transition a débuté il y à aujourd'hui
156 bus qui tourne dans la métropole sur
ses 156 bus 57 sont les dernières
générations du diesel mais à partir de
2019 tous les renouvellements des bus
qui seront effectués par la métropole
seront sur la transition énergétique
électrique ou biogaz
on est en train de voir mais en tout cas
on n'achète rompu de bus diesel dans
cette métropole
il en va du renouvellement des bus comme
pour celui les voitures des particuliers
l'avenir semble le plus probablement
nous mener vers un mix de plusieurs
énergies
il n'y aura pas de grand soir avec le
moteur thermique qui bascule vers le
tout électrique
il y aura toujours du thermique de
l'hybride de l'hybride rechargeable de
l'électrique 100% et à terme on aura
aussi de l'hydrogène qui est d'ailleurs
une autre forme d'électrification
finalement au lieu d'avoir une batterie
dans laquelle en stock de l'énergie aie
qui alimente un moteur électrique
l'hydrogène s'est on fabrique l'énergie
en roulant autrement dit on à du gaz qui
est stocké dans des bonbonnes qui est
transformé en courant électrique par une
pile à combustible est ensuite eh bien
on peut rouler pendant plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres sachant que
l'hydrogène à cette grande force que
l'on peut recharger la voiture en
seulement trois minutes
l'hydrogène serait donc l'une des autres
grandes pistes à explorer et là aussi
l'indre et loire pourrait devenir un
acteur majeur
plusieurs industriels sont sur les rangs
aux côtés du cea de mon déjà à la pointe
de la recherche sur les réservoirs et
les piles à combustible le site 10 au
parc a souri ni pourrais quand elle y
accueillir la première grande station de
recharge du précieux gaz
[Musique]
il